so you know yesterday I was in San
Antonio at one of our conferences we had
about 2,000 people there in David
Goggins was one of the keynotes we had a
great time afterwards with these guys
rented out the entire Alamo in San
Antonio dinner food entertainment drinks
open bar and one of the guys comes up to
me young guy and says Pat what can I do
to increase the speed of success I want
to win but I want to win faster is there
a hack or hacks I said there's different
hacks but I'll give you the one hack
that'll give you a big edge I said
assuming you are willing to work hard
you are clear on what you want you have
desire and ambition to do it let's say
you have those because if you don't have
those it doesn't matter what I tell you
but let's assume you have those assuming
you have those right is there a hack
absolutely I said years ago to this kid
I was talking to was about 20 to 23
years old I said years ago a guy who was
in Hollywood came up to me said Pat what
is the fastest way for me to make it in
Hollywood I said why are you asking me
I'm a business case as well you went
from being a no-name guy in the world of
business you come out of the military
and have a degree you made it so I guess
some of the principles can apply what
would you say I said if I were to tell
you the one hack it probably would be
this I said there is nothing more
powerful than finding a running mate who
believes in you nothing more powerful
who believes in you understands your
flaws understands your mistakes
understands those things but you guys
have a strong bond together you trust
each other nothing leaks between the two
of you guys because you guys back each
other up you find that running made
things change let me explain to you
Hollywood look at Hollywood if you
wanted to make it in Hollywood Vince
Vaughn and Jon Favreau dude how many
movies have them together many go
Kalinin
so many just I've been Vince Vaughn Jon
Favreau movies after movie swingers
couples retreat movies after movies
after movies look at Julia Roberts and
Richard Gere look at the drew Barrymore
and Adam Sandler look at Jennifer
Lawrence and Bradley Cooper look at that
that's a running mate right think about
Charlie Munger and Warren Buffett very
opposite look at Welles and Fargo ends
up becoming Wells Fargo look at Hewlett
and Packard ends up becoming
hewlett-packard look at Steve Wozniak
and Jobs ends up becoming Apple do you
really think Apple is gonna exist
without
Wozniak you really think I interviewed
Wozniak ten years ago you think Steve
Jobs would be who he is in the history
books if there wasn't a Wozniak no way
in the world you think Jordan is Jordan
without Pippen do you think Pippen is
who he's without George so what is the
moral the story here today for you look
a couple of things one everybody says
well how do I find a running mate
number one b8 great running mate so
everybody wants you as a running mate
the number one thing to attract in a
great running mate is by being a great
running mate your team the person you're
looking for that you want to run with
he's gonna sit there saying oh my gosh
this guy's amazing he wants to win as
bad as me if not more this is great I
love working with a guy like this you
gotta be that so when then you become
that and he start kind of scoping things
out and you start looking at people
saying oh I'd love to have that as a run
man I'd love to have this guy's a
running mate in a world of business your
after year after year
I'm always looking at hiring people to
be running mates and I'm looking at
people that one is as bad as I do that
have different things that I don't have
and every single time every single time
you see somebody who wins at a pace
faster than anybody else you will find
somebody that had a running late Iverson
never won a championship he didn't have
a running mate LeBron didn't win a
championship the first time around at
Cleveland he had a run and make the
second time or Dwyane Wade the third
time around he won in Cleveland he had a
run in Maine to Kyrie Irving no matter
what game you look at it's all about a
run image so I got a message for you
what do you want as a running mate and
who you need to be trying a running mate
and if you do have your running mate
right now does he want it as bad as you
the shoe one is as bad as bad as you do
you want it as bad as they do because if
the two of you do the industries didn't
hold on to very very some whatever
company you're in whatever business
you're in the marketplace is gonna know
about you extremely fast extremely about
the way understand this running make
doesn't mean that you guys get along all
the time a running mate doesn't mean
that you guys don't behind closed doors
drop a couple f-bombs and curse did you
know you have some bad falling-out
moments of pissed off at each other and
like ticked off at each other but at the
end of the day when the dust settles
you come back to yourself and you
realize this guy this girl this lady
wants it as bad as I do and if anything
else he has a broken character he keeps
his word doesn't have a loose lift we
respect each other and the essence of
known we want to do something bit
together and we're having fun and we're
enjoying it even through the madness if
you find that do whatever you can to
maintain that relationship because as
good as things are right now when the
running mate and your success starts
compounding everybody in the world
starts finding out about the two of you
guys so one be a great running mate to
go find your running mate three when you
do find it do whatever you can to run
for a long time together because crazy
things can happen and we have a great
week everybody take care bye bye
you
[Music]